what does kistama have to do to unlock
the door to number 10. I think turn the
anger
and frankly discuss with the
conservatives into a positive appetite
for labor and that's what this week's
conference is all about because the late
party conference is one of those weeks
in the year one actually a rare week in
the year in terms of the coverage we get
where the voters can look through the
window judge whether we've got our house
in order and listen to the offer we're
making to the country and I think last
year in terms of the changes here made
to the labor party people could see he
was getting the house in order I think
what you're seeing this year and you'll
certainly get from kirstalma speech late
this afternoon and you've got in in
bucket loads from Rachel Reeves
yesterday in her speeches I hope our
country's next Chancellor first woman
Chancellor you know we've gone further
we're ready to get the country back in
order because on so many fronts things
are broken whether it's the economy our
Public Services the sense of Law and
Order in our country and labor has
serious people with a serious plan to
get Britain working again and to give
Britain a fresh start it needs how much
does each Rewritten this piece
uh I I think all of us
are frankly are still recovering from
our Jaws hitting the floor last week
with that budget from quasi-quarting and
the real world consequences we're seeing
overnight the withdrawal of uh mortgage
products tells us about the extent to
which the chancellor our own Chancellor
in this country has frightened the
markets and and and as a result lenders
having to change the offer they're
making to Consumers this is just the tip
of the iceberg if interest rates go up
in the way that some people are
predicting that's going to be huge
additional cost to people with mortgages
and and what was the Chancellor's answer
yesterday don't worry folks in November
I'm going to come out with some new
fiscal rules I.E I've ignored all the
ones I've already got and I'm rewriting
the rules of making it up as I go along
this isn't serious leadership it's a
reckless Gamble and as Rachel Reeves
said yesterday it's not the chance law
or List trust that are going to be
paying the price for this he's gambling
with other people's money and we're
seeing the consequences for that in real
world consequences right now which will
affect family finances in the middle of
a cost of living Christ my question how
much is he Rewritten this speech
I've not been looking over his shoulder
I'm sure he's talked to you about it yes
he has and um I think the fundamentals
remain the same our analysis of where
the country has gotten wrong it it you
know it's not new we've had 12 years of
this now 12 years of the conservatives
making Reckless short-term economic
decisions which haven't worked making
decisions which are short-term missed in
public services which means they're now
largely broken
and Reckless short-term misdecisions
which mean that a whole range of things
that really matter to people yeah the
leader must have Rewritten his speech in
order to take in what's happened of
course
with the budget yeah of of of course but
you know we're determined to make short
the next election
we've got a serious plan that is both I
guess radical in its ambition but also
reassuring because I think people need
to know that there are still some
serious grown-up people in Westminster
that there is a serious alternative
government available and we're used to
sort of Left Right divides in in
politics and some of the conventional
um choices that people always have
between conservative policies and labor
policies we've now got the central
dividing line which is also responsible
labor versus irresponsible conservatives
what are we going to do about people who
want to borrow money to for a mortgage
you know that three lenders are already
withdrawn I'm guessing that is just the
tip of the iceberg
what would you say to them
um I'd say the Cavalry is coming with
labor on on two fronts one is
essentially two years away people are
worrying about their mortgage yeah
tomorrow and the next day and the day
yeah and so what are you saying to the
lenders and that's a fair challenge but
also Kate that's the one we're answering
at this conference you know why is it
frustrating for me being on your program
as an opposition politician because we
we can oppose we can criticize we can
challenge the government we're not in
the driving seat making decisions we've
had enough of that and I think you've
seen at the labor conference this week a
real change in tone in emphasis in
optimism a seriousness about the labor
party and it determinants um the viewers
that are watching this morning lenders
you potentially could be empowering two
years time is what you're saying what
you're hoping these people these lenders
will have to work with you yeah that's
right so what are you saying to them now
so two things one is Rachel roof set out
yesterday we've got a serious economic
plan to provide certainty and stability
for business investors to restore
consumer and business confidence I think
people look to Rachel Reeves not as the
shadow Chancellor but as the chancellor
our country needs I think that's the
first thing that provides the conditions
for a stable housing market secondly
grasping the nettle of Reform we need in
the housing market what's one of the
primary things we need to do address
housing Supply so building more homes
homes to buy homes to rent affordable
homes that would make an enormous
difference what about today and tomorrow
and the next day what are you saying to
the lenders
well I'd say to I'd say to the lenders
I I appreciate the conservatives have
made your job so much harder I
appreciate you need to revise the
products that you're offering consumers
as far as you can you know remember the
fact that just over a decade ago that
the country helped Financial Services
out of the massive black hole that dug
themselves into insofar as you can with
the conditions the conservatives have
given you please do your best to look
after consumers at this time think about
these families that are worried about
their mortgage payments really want to
get on the housing ladder have been
scrimping and saving to get that first
deposit to get on that first rung of the
housing ladder and now can see that
dream of home ownership slipping away do
your best to support those families but
my central message because I'm not
interested in opposition and what we're
saying today I'm interested in what we
want to do after the next election the
Cavalry is coming with labor we've got
serious people with a serious plan that
would make an enormous difference to
families right across the country and to
businesses who are the backbone of our
economy and will be the Bedrock of
economic growth I heard
um the boss described as Tony Blair 2.0
is that a compliment or an insult to
look at Tony Blair's record of winning
elections and delivering real change in
our country I think and I you know put
it this way I I've been a long-standing
fan of kirst armor if you told me when
he was first elected leader of the labor
party that he would have taken us from
that crushing defeat in 2019 worst
defeat since 1935 to a position today
looking at some of the opinion polls
where we're sort of you know I I think
kind of double looking as labor
politicians thinking you know look at
these polls look at what it would
deliver remarkable transformation I
guess the one thing I do want to say
though to your viewers in the context of
those polls is two things one we're not
taking any voters for granted we're
going to work hard to earn people's
trust
and two we're not relying on the
conservatives to fail to be in
government we've got a positive serious
alternative to offer the country and at
the next election I don't want people to
vote for labor as the least worst option
I want people to go to The Ballot Box
voting to give change a chance with
labor with the Hope belief and
conviction we can deliver real change
for people across our country what a
problem you're going to inherit though
when it comes to the economy of the
country and that's why Kay you know
often changes the biggest risk and
people are sometimes frightened of
change up straight away but risks are
come to the point about tax let me at
this point the risk now for our country
isn't change with labor it's continuity
with the conservatives and on taxes we
have made the running against the
conservatives on personal taxation I
don't think National Insurance would be
reversed I don't think the basic rate of
income tax would be being cut without
labor making a real run on the argument
that says conservatives have gone for
the pockets of working people as the
first and last resort
um well you saw yesterday from late from
labor from Rachel Reeves that serious
plan for economic growth which would
inject both long-term growth in the
economy whilst at the same time
delivering the you know against the big
challenge of our time in terms of
climate change you know
yeah there won't be an increase in in
base in operate tax though back to 45
we're bringing back you know what we're
going to do which I'm [ __ ] a hoop about
serious Workforce plan for the NHS the
biggest expansion of Staff training in
the history Okay the reason I ask you
about 45 because it's actually only
about it only costs about 2 million
pounds which is a drop in the bucket
compared to the problems that you'll be
inherited okay but here's the thing Kate
especially when people say oh top rate
of tax you know what difference would
that really make in terms of public
Champions I am now able as I think the
country's next Health secretary to
double the number of medicine training
places at University to have an
additional 10 000 places for training
for nursing and Midwifery uh places
double the number of District nurses put
5 000 more Health visitors into the
Health Service a serious long-term
Workforce plan so that we can arrest
this decline in the NHS
but that's what I'm spending the two
billion pounds on you know Rachel Rachel
and let me tell you on behalf of the
rest of the Shadow Camp
it's not easy getting money out of
Rachel Reeves because she wants to make
sure that every penny is well spent she
tests our assumptions and our demands
and and but that two billion pounds do
you know what that would deliver it will
deliver the Bedrock for the for the
rebuilding and renewal of the NHS for
the 21st century it will also help the
economy there are a quarter of a million
how do you start to pay off our debt
because I'll tell you why Kate because
there are a quarter of million people in
our country who are economically
inactive for no other reason than they
are sick and they are tired of waiting
if we get those people treated faster we
get those people back into the labor
market that's one of the drivers of
growth if we invest in the way that
Rachel outlined yesterday in the new
industries of the future in a plan to
put you know new industry new jobs in
parts of the country that have been
de-industrialized and left behind for
too long that's how you get growth into
the economy you don't get growth in the
economy by letting you know boom time
for bankers and abolishing the cap on
Bankers bonuses you don't get growth in
the economy by making a corporation tax
cut
that's what they say I'll tell you what
we'll look at the numbers I'll tell you
what we're talking about numbers and
looking at the latest opinion poll labor
17 points in the lead but when it comes
to who would be the better prime
minister the latest poll that we've got
Redfield and Wilton strategies they say
40 say Liz trust 36 Kia stama
and that's why we're not taking people
for granted we know we've got more to do
to turn disaffection with the
conservatives into a positive option for
for labor but it goes back to the point
I made earlier really
if you'd have told me when Kia was first
elected leader of light party that he'd
be able to grip this party and make it
serious and and fit for government in
such a short space of time I wouldn't
have believed that I'm not sure even Kia
would have thought it as well but the
late the last hundred polls labor has
been ahead in almost all of them but
when it comes to the actual leader he's
not he's not it's they think that Liz
truss who a lot of people think that is
mismanaging the economy is still a
better prime minister than kids talk
directly to those voters who haven't
made their mind up on Kirsten and talk
about that well polls to change and can
be changed so let me talk to those
people who haven't made their mind up
about kirstana for kirst armor I work
with is serious he's got serious
experience outside politics he does his
job seriously I think he'd be a serious
prime minister secondly the care star
Marino is in touch with the concerns of
ordinary people across the country
wasn't born with a silver spoon in his
mouth his family aren't particularly
wealthy in terms of his immediate family
and you know he understands the pressure
that people he understands the pressure
people under but third and in stark
contrast to Liz trust he has got the
answers that our country needs whether
it's rebuilding economic growth
rebuilding our public services and
rebuilding a sense of hope and optimism
about future rebuilding Britain's place
in the world you're right if we win the
next general election labor will inherit
crises on all fronts crises at home
crises abroad crisis in terms of the
economy now some of those things like
the war in Ukraine are beyond the
control of this conservative government
and I wouldn't blame them for that but
there are a whole load of problems that
are made in Downing Street and after 12
years of conservative government asking
this lot to fix those crises they've
created is like asking the arsonist to
put out the fire they started it's not
going to happen quick thought before I
let you go on the Liverpool Dockers are
you going to join them on the picket
line no we're going to do one better
actually we're going to deliver a labor
government that improves The Fortunes of
working people across the country in two
years time but you won't join them on
the picket line that's our job no I want
to be in government I want to be solving
problems I don't want to be out on the
streets protest thing I've had enough of
that I did that when I was involved in
student politics I've done that for
years as a labor party member we are
tired of protesting we are ready to
govern that's how we make a difference
for working people final question should
Jeremy corbyn get the whip back no I
don't think you should thank you very
much thank you very much good to see you
thanks a lot